am i right in thinking your first taste
of hollywood was
mission impossible yes i was the uh
lead role in uh tom cruise's mission
impossible yeah yeah
no i was believing you i was
no they believe you they're
who did you actually play i played women
at desk
now you remember but didn't but did you
because you were in the famous scene i
was in the the infamous scene yeah so
this is tom this is where he broke his
foot
yeah but now you're on the other side
you're in the window yeah you can sort
of see
i think if you sort of zoom in a little
bit more
and if you keep zooming in you can see
that i'm sort of behind that window
were you really behind the video i was
really behind the window giving the
performance of a lifetime
so what is he flying to kick you yeah
yeah he's trying to congratulate me on
my performance
and then you shut the window and ruined
his performance yeah
he broke his ankle he kicked the
building and broke his ankle yeah he was
supposed to
land but his foot slammed into the wall
of the building
and they had to stop production for
months but i got there in the end
did you have to audition for a woman i
did yeah i had to go to
an audition room and they said like okay
so pretend that you're at your desk and
you're eating lunch
and then tom cruise slammed into the
window and so i was like
very good yeah
[Music]